video games
gonna jump straight in here Unreal
Tournament 3 goddammit this game was
just the absolute best came in 2007
reasons why I love this game it still
looks great even though came out eight
years ago how they years ago hey guys
seven years ago okay good this still
looks reason number two why I like this
game you start with a skateboard
hoverboard
hey Q look I'm on my sweet hoverboard
check it out we put in all these
vehicles and every realize it was really
hard to get around if he didn't weren't
in a vehicle so we just stuck in a
hoverboard reason number three I love
this game vehicles much like the weapons
you have like alternate fires like and
jump in this or I could squish people if
you find a vehicle that's on your team
you can use this like glass to thing you
have like this and just hook on be like
my brothers they were like like a kid
with a bungee cord and a skateboard and
his his friends who really shouldn't
have taken his mom's SUV look at this I
can just fall I'm like oh myself and
they get back up again
where was the anvil there was an anvil
here somewhere there you go Apple Avril
Lavigne hey what's up check out my sweet
gun and it's named after Canadian pop
star oh yes I got the funky car check
out this car it's like a normal car but
then it's got razor blades that stick
out and you can chop people's faces off
also got minds of some sort no one's
over here so that's where you are you
piece of [ __ ]
well it's got a boost but what you're
gonna use to get the hell out of here
attack the enemy Oh suck on this oh you
joking proper board it over me I've got
this as well you jerk oh yeah you think
you're gonna get me
I know the secret ensign entrance jerk
you're home a dick I didn't work out as
well as I thought I might oh god how did
he hit me Redeemer for those of you
don't know is am a nuclear missile a
1-shot nuclear missile that's pretty
devastating hold my dick Oh still got
the slow motion thing on that's great
I'm gonna make getting hitting at
monster kills so much easier boom here
we go
gonna kill anyone yeah look at Anyang
explosion and the ant trail was really
impressed so I kind of translocate this
guy yeah second and here we go I'm going
upstairs avignon this yeah oh god Thomas
alright next time somebody shot it out
of the air probably because it's a
massive red glowing yawn cat watch me
noscope this guy boom headshot
ah just just hunting heads see we're on
the same page me and Ian answer dude I'm
gonna impact one of you guys Bam Bam
where's Mellie gone in the history of
video games
still haven't figured out how to
actually works how they go taking the
scenic route oh for God's sake they're
way better at shooting out of there than
they used to be I turned you into bones
flat counter probably the best in the
game especially in as I'm using it
especially a toy Kardos because it takes
shots around corners I'm gonna ricochet
it and stuff oh god damn it
I guess there's way less weapons in this
version of UT and there was they got rid
of got rid of the Ripper I guess but
they kept the bio rifle for some reason
I'm [ __ ] it I'm no idea
fire up is Nino Gonzales need to fire
rifles awful awesome I know man but
shoots one lump or hold it and just goes
like globule it's like a mine like a
biome mine which no one will ever won
across cuz it's this big green lump on
the floor
you got it you gotta keep one just in
the chamber you got to keep one in the
chamber see it's useless you're wrong
Benito here's the Redeemer yawn count
for everyone
and kills remain killing spree monster
to video game I don't think a monster
kill should count if you kill yourself
but I'll take it
epic games away and havoc trust head of
my pelvic thrust yeah
welcome to Unreal Tournament everyone
you feel the impact of death
there you go you'll feel the impact of
that one in a moment Unreal Tournament 3
is available on Steam for the very low
price of $19.99 it's on sale quite a lot
though the guys tell me so sometimes it
goes down to like 5 bucks which is
pretty good and yes you should check
that out there is an unreal pack as well
which I believe has I'm gonna say unreal
unreal - The Awakening on a tournament
or a tournament I don't think that's
2003 but maybe I so for 3 and a bunch of
other stuff including the expansion
packs for LA I believe there was an
expansion pack for the first unreal game
and not for any tournaments though so
yeah maybe check that one out if you've
you've fallen out of favor with the the
series or you haven't played it very
often or played it very much or if you
like me and you have a disk-based copy
of one in tournaments but didn't have a
disk drive in your computer so he just
bought it again which is why I don't
have a mortgage thanks everyone for
watching rounder meketa this week this
next week I've no idea what the hell it
is because I'm badly organized sorry Dan
mejor ik but it'll be something cool if
you have any suggestions a tiny word
wire on Twitter this week's the point is
about the Unreal franchise there are two
eggs with one basket whole other kettle
of ballpark's thanks very much for
watching I'll see you guys next week